ROGER MARTINEZ: In
today's IT world,
most developers wear
many different hats,
and you're probably
no exception.
But managing
applications designed
for different platforms
can be quite a chore.
The problem is it's hard to
handle all the architecture
and upkeep required
to do such a task.
For example, dealing with
your own provisioning.
Not to mention all
the work to ensure
that everything is secure.
What if you could wrap your
workloads in a common package,
like docker containers,
that you can run
on prem and in any major cloud?
Thankfully, this is exactly
what Google Cloud Run is for.
Cloud Run is a fully managed
serverless compute platform.
It automatically scales and
load balances your stateless
containers on a pay
per request basis
so you can do what
matters most--
build great applications.
It's driven by portable
Docker-based images that
can run almost anywhere, letting
you leverage the best of what
you need in the cloud.
Containerization lets
you have full control
over your runtime
environment without giving up
the benefits of serverless.
Whether you're a pro at
containers or looking
to build your first
containerized app,
Cloud Run lets you get your
code into production in seconds.
Simply run a gcloud command
to deploy your stateless
container, and Cloud
Run will do the rest.
Listen to requests and events,
pass them to your code,
and scale them up and
down to meet user demand.
The best part?
You can do all this in
your favorite language,
and you only pay for the
requests that you process.
Cloud Run is a great
solution for running
your containerized
HTTP applications
if you don't have specialized
DevOps requirements.
But why stop there?
Cloud Run can be used to help
multiple kinds of workloads,
not just HTTP-based ones.
Let's take a closer look at
what you can do with Cloud Run.
The first major use
case for Cloud Run
is event orchestration.
Cloud Run has the
ability to listen
to events from other
Cloud components,
handle webhooks, and
manage distributing
events and workloads
to other components.
This built-in ability
makes it straightforward
for your application to
handle complex event needs.
Another good set of
workloads for Cloud Run
involves data processing.
When you need to
adjust and transform
large amounts of data,
Cloud Run provides
the infrastructure
your workloads need
to handle auto-scaling,
authorization, and event
triggers via a Pub/Sub
model of communication.
Cloud Run leverages the
power of Google Cloud
to provide these
features for you
so you can build
complex scalable data
pipelines while saving time
spent on backend confusion.
Of course, this
type of flexibility
also makes building
microservices and developing
APIs a lot easier.
Simply configure your stateless
container to listen for
and handle ATP requests,
webhooks, or CloudEvents,
and you've got the ability
to deploy a federation
of microservices in no time.
Advanced features, such
as traffic splitting,
audit logging, and
custom domains,
are built in for
when you need them.
And with the power of Google
Cloud to client APIs and Cloud
workflows, Cloud Run
becomes a powerful tool
to help you automate
complex processes that
require coordination of
distributed services and APIs,
like G Suite or Google
Cloud's ML and AI offerings.
If you're looking to build
a mobile or web-based
application, then you
know how important
a fast development cycle and
native local host developer
experience are.
Cloud Run makes creating
client-side frontend services
easy, and seamlessly interfaces
with storage, databases,
and other services
on the back end.
All at the same power,
scalability, and demand,
regardless of your
traffic profile.
So whether you're a seasoned
IT professional or just
discovering the flexibility
of container-based workloads,
Cloud Run is right
there to help you build
great portable applications.
For more information,
check out the links
in the description below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to our Cloud YouTube
channel for more great content
on building your application.
[MUSIC PLAYING]